entonces hagamos un repaso de qué pasó
entre el año 2000 y el 2004 bueno de
hecho entre el 2000 y el 2006 fue en ese
momento del que se generó una burbuja de
endeudamiento una burbuja en los precios
inmobiliarios bueno financiarse se hizo
fácil entonces vamos a escribirlo
financiarse se hizo cada vez más fácil o
al menos se bajaron los requerimientos y
progresivamente se hizo más y más y más
fácil cada año que pasó entonces más
personas se endeudaron por un hogar
vamos a escribirlo más personas se
endeudaron por una casa por un hogar
como consecuencia se incrementó la
demanda de todas las casas como vimos en
el artículo de new york times' en el
primer vídeo sin embargo aumentó la
demanda de manera artificial porque el
ingreso de las personas no aumentaban la
población recuerdan que tampoco
aumentaba o al menos estamos suponiendo
que no iba a aumentar mucho es decir no
crece tan rápido y todo esto permitió a
las personas que estaban alquilando que
ahora no era necesario ahorrar su pago
inicial su enganche para comprar una
casa
y ahora lo que hacían era simple y
sencillamente pedir un préstamo por lo
tanto esto hace que más personas estén
peleando o compitiendo por la misma casa
y bueno entonces la pregunta este vídeo
era porque entonces la gente se está
endeudando cada vez más así que
regresemos a los años preciosos de 1990
por ahí no han hecho mejor regresemos al
momento en el que llegamos a lo clásico
que pasa cuando queremos un préstamo
hipotecario bueno tradicionalmente yo
iba al banco y el oficial de créditos
del banco me daba el dinero y a cambio
yo le doy una cierta tasa de interés y
este de aquí soy yo pero bueno toma nota
el oficial de créditos del banco lo que
se va a encargar es de revisar que no se
pierda dinero en esta transacción del
banco si él te va a dar un millón pues
entonces él va a querer estar seguro que
si tú pierdes su trabajo si a ti te
arrestan si tú te vas del país si lo que
sea él va a recibir su millón de regreso
y es justo por eso que en esos momentos
te pedían el 20 o el 25 por ciento de
enganche además te pedían que tuvieras
un buen historial crediticio
y te pedían además que tuvieras un buen
trabajo porque si este banquero o este
oficial de créditos del banco se da
cuenta que no le prestó el dinero a la
persona indicada entonces él se va a
meter en un severo problema y también
visto desde otra manera la cantidad de
dinero que le pagan con la cantidad de
personas a las cuales les prestó el
dinero pero que además sean confiables
sean gentes responsables bueno eso en el
modelo tradicional y bueno entonces qué
es lo que pasó a partir del año 2000 lo
que pasó es lo que se conoce como la
titulización del mercado y bueno justo
esto pasó un poco antes con empresas
como fannie mae and freddie mac pero voy
a hacer un vídeo separado hablándoles de
estas dos empresas aunque déjenme
contarles rápido que las empresas freddy
median freddie mac esencialmente tenían
los mismos estándares daban préstamos
con un 20 por ciento de enganche y los
famosos préstamos conformes es decir
tenías que tener un buen trabajo un buen
historial crediticio sin embargo estas
dos empresas freddie mae and freddie mac
fueron los primeros que compraron los
préstamos a los bancos locales
sin embargo estas dos empresas fueron
las primeras que empezaron a cambiar
todo este asunto pero bueno después hay
otro vídeo hablando de estas dos
empresas aquí estoy yo otra vez si
estamos en el año 2000 entonces en lugar
de ir por un crédito al banco voy con mi
corredor de hipotecas el más popular en
eeuu es el c fsm y espero que esta
horita no hayan quebrado y bueno
esencialmente lo que pasaba es que ellos
me van a darme un millón de pesos es
decir un crédito hipotecario y entonces
voy a aceptar y voy a tener que pagar
una cierta tasa de interés sin embargo
después todo el país va a querer hacer
lo mismo entonces va a haber mucha gente
que quiera comprar sus casas y estos
corredores hipotecarios les van a
prestar a cada uno un millón de dólares
y entonces lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente esta compañía va a vender sus
deudas supongamos que venden esos
créditos por ejemplo a la empresa vamos
a llamarlo vean usted y espero que esta
gente no me demande creo que ellos
tienen problemas mayores que de mandarme
pero
esperemos que no me demanden por ver mis
vídeos en youtube entonces esta segunda
empresa lo que va a hacer es juntar
todos los pagarés de estas personas y
después van a vender todas estas deudas
todo esto a los inversionistas entonces
ahora mis pagos van a ir a estos
inversionistas y suponte que hay dice
inversionistas porque mi pluma está
pintando horrible yo sé que uso un
bolígrafo horrible que no pinta muy bien
pero lo importante es que te quede el
concepto les recomiendo que vean los
vídeos de títulos respaldados por
hipotecas y también los de obligaciones
de deuda colateralizada para que
entienda exactamente a qué me refiero
con todo este flujo de dinero pero al
fondo es porque de este proceso lo que
está pasando en todo el país es sólo ser
transaccionales sólo están haciendo los
trámites para el préstamo el préstamo se
lleva temporalmente y que están haciendo
un poco de diligencia de vida ya cambio
de eso la empresa que es un corredor de
hipoteca acaba de obtener una tarifa
fija para hacer la transacción no sé tal
vez se obtenga cinco mil dólares sólo
por hacer los trámites para
hipoteca no y luego la siguiente empresa
bear stearns va a obtener todas estas
deudas las va a empaquetar y luego las
va a vender a los inversionistas en el
proceso bernstein se cortan y esta
empresa está haciendo esto para millones
de hipotecas a la vez está a los miles
de millones de dólares así que esta
segunda empresa también esencialmente va
a conseguir una tasa como agente
hipotecario por supuesto que va a ser
una tasa enorme y a continuación los
inversionistas van a obtener un cierto
pago de los intereses no y digamos que
si esta tasa de interés si estoy
pensando en un 7% y los otros millones
de personas están pagando un 7% también
los inversionistas están consiguiendo un
7 por ciento de su dinero y eso parece
una propuesta muy razonable y bueno por
supuesto la atención de los
inversionistas de prestar este dinero
que esencialmente están dando este
dinero a los banqueros de inversión que
a su vez están dando este dinero a todo
el país y es aquí justo donde millón de
dólares vive la única razón para que los
inversionistas den su dinero
es que ellos tienen mucha confianza en
que estos préstamos son muy buenos
porque fíjate realmente los
inversionistas ni saben quién soy ellos
no saben nada de mi trabajo así que los
inversionistas dependen de la otra
empresa que les diga que estos son
buenos préstamos y aquí entran otras
empresas las agencias de clasificación
estas agencias lo que hacen es decir si
realmente conviene o no conviene
invertir esa cantidad de dinero a las
personas a las cuales les van a dar el
préstamo ellos revisan la tasa histórica
de incumplimiento
ellos dicen wow estas hipotecas
realmente no han tenido un cumplimiento
y ustedes pueden pensar acerca de por
qué no no se ha debido a que los precios
de la vivienda se van para arriba o lo
que sea así que vamos a decir que estas
hipotecas realmente no se han incumplido
y hay una posibilidad muy alta de que
van a ser capaz de obtener todo su
dinero de vuelta así que a estas
empresas les vamos a dar una
clasificación doble a muy buenas porque
no han incumplido y entonces este
inversionista que podría ser por ejemplo
el banco central de china o podría ser
un fondo de cuba
podría ser un conjunto de personas o
inclusive pueden ser que sean los bancos
de inversión propios a veces en realidad
hacen esto solamente para ganar un
dinero extra bueno en general estos
inversionistas que no saben realmente a
quién le han prestado el dinero o qué
tipo de clasificación crediticia tenían
nada lo han hecho con un gran salto de
fe y también con una gran posibilidad de
quedarse con un buen dinero bueno
después hubo inversionistas que querían
aún más hacer esto son común esto es
genial un poco de riesgo que estoy
obteniendo por un rendimiento bastante
bueno con mi dinero y como es una tasa
de interés mucho más grande que ponerla
en el banco se arriesgaban entonces lo
que hacen es comprar las letras del
tesoro verdad y por lo tanto cada vez
más y más y más personas empezaban a
invertir en las hipotecas de las
personas y entonces con toda esa
cantidad de dinero la empresa inicial lo
que va a hacer es buscar a personas que
califiquen cada vez con menos trámites
es decir lo que está buscando es
encontrar a más personas que quieran
hipotecas y que por lo tanto se endeuden
un poco y entonces justo aquí es donde
empiezan a bajarlo
estándares porque nos encontramos con
que incluso se bajan los estándares no
es moroso en sus hipotecas y tal vez en
el siguiente vídeo te diga un poco mejor
por qué está pasando todo esto pero
bueno lo importante es que la empresa
inicial a los corredores de hipotecas lo
que hacían era darle a estos
inversionistas normas aún más bajas y
por lo tanto recibir más dinero y por lo
tanto prestar más dinero es decir a todo
el país le encantaba esta idea porque
cada vez que hacen una transacción
acaban de obtener algo de dinero y luego
le dan a la hipoteca de inversión al
banquero a los paquetes y luego se vende
a los inversionistas
así es como obtienes tú tu dinero del
préstamo de tu casa
los inversionistas aman esto los bancos
los bancos de inversión aman esto y
también las personas que están
recibiendo el dinero imagínate los
inversionistas parecen muy felices
porque siguen dando el dinero en este
sistema por así decirlo a pesar de que
podrían ser leyendo el periódico y ya
que las normas están bajando sin embargo
llegaron los valores por defecto que se
fueron muy bajos en ese periodo de
tiempo y es lo que vamos a ver en el
siguiente vídeo